and welcome to the second draw
television society and institution of
Engineering and Technology public
lecture
I'm Tim Davey I'm chairing tonight and
you know when we conceived of this
lecture series our aim was to hear from
some of the world's finest minds who
work in the spaces that bridge
cutting-edge science and technology with
human creativity and media the amazing
response and we were lucky to be there
last year who those of us who saw Mike
Lynch in full flow suggesting we were
onto something and the excitement in the
room tonight speaks to the enduring
appeal in my mind of public lectures in
sparking our imagination in many ways
and I really believe this we are lucky
enough to be enjoying another Golden Age
of advancement that demands public
engagement and debate over 200 years it
was a rather precocious Humphrey Davy
that was WOW in crowds and causing
carries traffic jams with sellout
lectures on the nature of human progress
and scientific knowledge noticeably as a
friend of Coleridge he was fascinated by
the intersection of the subjective and
the technical and the possibilities the
endless possibilities that this throws
up so tonight at this wonderful
institution we continue that tradition
with our very special speaker demis
hassabis as abyss
Demi's will talk for 35 minutes or so
then he will open up for Q&A and I'll be
conducting what have the lights up and
we're really up for a good old
discussion with you guys as you know
demi sees acknowledged as a world
leading thinker in the realm of AI which
in recent years has become where the
hottest topics dominating the media and
the imagination of the public you know
in my world we're an ab recent BBC
survey which was looking at which jobs
are at risk of computerization we
attracted 2.3 million pageviews people
viewing that and seeing how safe they
were Demi sleaze needs little
introduction but I have to say his
achievements put even the highest
achievers CV deeply in the shade
Chessmaster of 13 world games
championship
winner five times running successful
poker player particularly impressive
double first in computer science at
Cambridge a pioneering video games
developer leader of numerous important
pieces of research in the field of
neuroscience notably his landmark paper
on the similarities of how we shape
memory and how we imagined the future
was a landmark and breakthrough piece of
research and then of course found of
deep mind in 2011 which was then sold to
Google in 2014 with demouth becoming VP
engineering with special responsibility
for AI deep mind has set out a goal of
solving intelligence a humble objective
specifically
domitius says he is involved in building
something that can expect the unexpected
gracefully I think that's probably a
great brief for an audience of a public
lecture demouth the floor is yours well
thanks very much Tim for that very
generous introduction so it's a real
pleasure to be here I'm giving this
lecture and I'm going to talk about
artificial intelligence and its impact
on the future in fact it could be the
relatively near term future so AI is
really the science of making machine
smart and I got into AI firstly through
the medium of games and games started
for me with chess as Tim said I started
playing chess when I was very young at
for age of four and I think if you play
chess seriously from such a young age
and you're quite an introspective kid
which I was then you start thinking a
lot about how is it that your brain is
coming up with these moves these ideas
that allow you to play this game and win
these games and I started thinking a lot
about this as I got into my teenage
years and I lied with that I got into
computing I actually bought my first
computer as a tech spectrum here 48k
with some winnings from a chess
tournament and when I was about eight
years old
and I start to teach myself how to
program and I think very early on in the
engineers in the audience will I think
resonate with this I sort of realized on
an intuitive level that this computer is
a kind of special type of machine you
know most machines like cars and planes
they allow us to they extend our
physical capabilities you know cars
allow us to move faster than we can run
planes allow us to fly but I think
computers do that but in the realm of
our minds and they really extend the
capabilities of the brain and this
really came clear to me when I used to
write my first programs and did sort of
basic math calculations and other things
which it really struck me you could set
something running overnight and then go
to sleep and then you'd wake up the next
morning and your computer will assault
some problem for you whilst you were
asleep
so this felt like a really powerful in
some ways magical tool so my love of
computers and my love of games obviously
came together in a kind of obvious way
in the designing of video games and
actually this is one of the reasons I
accepted to do this lecturers I love the
idea as Tim said of the confluence of
bringing together RTS and the creative
arts and the IET and sort of Engineering
and that's why I got into commercial
video games because at the time this is
sort of like the early and mid 90s
computer games were really pushing the
cutting edge of engineering and even the
machines that were being built to run
these games so I remember the debate in
the 90s about you know Intel was
bringing out their new Pentium
processors and people were sort of
saying well how much more power do we
need to run our word processors and
spreadsheets and you know davin we got
all the computing power we need and
actually one of the answers was that if
we wanted more more realistic and
complex games then we would require more
more powerful computers with larger
memory and things like graphics chips so
for a long while games were actually
driving the development of cutting-edge
hardware and furthermore the games that
I used to sort of design and program all
involved AI as
core gameplay mechanic so probably my
best known game was called theme park
and which is some screenshots of it here
it came out in 94 and was very
successful and it was actually the first
game of its type so the idea here was
that you designed your own Disney World
and thousands of little people would
come in to your Disney World and kind of
play on your rides and that how
enjoyable they thought your theme park
was would sort of have an impact on
their emotions and how happy they were
and then that fed into the economics
model about how much you could charge
them for the hamburgers and the balloons
so the better design your theme park was
the more money it made and then that
allowed you of course to expand the
theme park further so this game and
actually another game called Sim City
were the first sort of games that had AI
as a core gameplay component and really
spawned a whole genre of management
simulation games as they're called and
one of the reasons these games were so
popular is that the AI adapted to the
way the player played the game so that
means that every single person who
played this game had a unique experience
and people used to send in I remember
into magazines game magazines and right
into us
I said showing what end-state they got
their theme park into and there was all
these amazing designs that people are
created that we had no idea could be
done even as the inventors of this game
so that really struck a chord with me
when I was around 16 17 years old when I
wrote this game and thinking about you
know maybe if I devoted my career to AI
advancing AI what an incredible
technology that could be so then after
having a career in getting games and
running my own games companies and
things I then went back to academia to
do a PhD in neuroscience which I felt
was another piece of the puzzle that I
needed before launching an effort like
deep mind I wanted to understand a bit
more about how the brain solved tough
problems like imagination and memory and
I specifically picked those topics to do
my PhD on because those are things that
at least back into mid 2000s were we
were not very good at doing
in computer algorithms so I wanted to to
look at the way the brain sold some of
these very very tough problems that we
didn't know yet how to imbue our
machines with and I'll come back to that
towards the second half of my talk so
all of these different experiences then
culminated in finally in setting up deep
mind in 2010 and really it's been a 20
year plus journey for me to get to this
point and have enough of what I thought
were the basic ingredients both on an
algorithmic level but also in terms of
the founding scientific team and making
those contacts to actually put together
something like deep mind and and
plausibly go after as big a mission as
solving intelligence so another way we
look at the company is as an Apollo
program for AI a sort of moonshot
project that really focuses on the very
ambitious long-term goals and we've
collected together 100 more than 100
actually new 150 now of the world's top
research scientists in this area so I
think the mind is by far now the biggest
collection of machine learning experts
anywhere in the world
and another thing we're experimenting
with of course apart from trying to
build AI is actually new ways to
organize scientific endeavor so what we
try to do a deep mind is really combine
the best form Silicon Valley startups
together with the best parts of that you
find in the in the best academic
Institute's like MIT UCL Cambridge and
so on and see if we confuse that into a
new hybrid way of doing science which is
more productive and extremely efficient
but still allows for extreme creativity
so our mission then as Tim said there we
articulate it in a kind of two-step way
so firstly we talk about solving
intelligence and we use the word solve
which is a kind of ambiguous word there
because actually what we mean what we're
interested in is is understanding
natural intelligence so the human mind
but also recreating that our
intelligence artificially and then step
two we want to use that technology to
help us solve everything else now you
know that
seem a little bit far-fetched possibly a
little bit fanciful to some of you but
we really believe actually that step 2
naturally follows on from step 1 if you
can solve intelligence and I hope by the
end of this talk you know you're you'll
agree with this conjecture
so more prosaically how are we going to
solve intelligence well what we're
trying to do a deep mind is to construct
the world's first general-purpose
learning machine and the key aspects of
this are the word general and learning
so we're at deep mind were only
interested in algorithms that learn for
themselves so they learn automatically
from raw experience or raw data so
they're not pre-programmed in any way so
what we're talking about here is
autonomous learning systems the second
thing is this idea of generality so what
we're interested in is the same system
actually be able to operate across a
wide range of tasks and environments out
of the box with no reconfiguration so of
course we have an example of such a
general learning system it's the human
mind where we're able to apply our minds
to almost endless number of different
tasks now I should say most of AI today
although it's a huge buzzword right now
and is very fashionable most of it AI is
not of this type of technology so we
call most AI actually internally a deep
mind narrow AI and what we mean by that
is pre-programmed AI that has been built
for in a bespoke way for one specific
task and actually most of the AI we
interact with everyday from Syria on
your phone to self-driving cars is
actually of this pre-programmed type of
AI and what we're insulin is what we
call artificial general intelligence
this idea of a general learning system
and perhaps still the most famous and
clearest example I can give of this is
the famous deep blue match against Garry
Kasparov of course this was a watershed
moment in AI when in the late 90s IBM's
deep blue beat Kasparov in a six-game
chess match but the interesting thing is
I came away from that match
actually more impressed by garry
kasparov mind than the deep-blue machine
because you know of course it was an
impressive engineering feat but deep
blue was programmed by an amazing team
of programmers along with a bunch of
chess grandmasters trying to distill
chess knowledge into an algorithmic sort
of construct and those programmers were
directly programming in the sword of
ideas and solutions into the machine
and of course what that meant is that
deep blue although it was very good at
chess it was no use for absolutely
anything else including strictly simpler
things like for example playing noughts
and crosses which any chess grandmaster
you could trivially teach them how to
play noughts and crosses but obviously
deep blue nothing that deep blue knew or
in its code would help it with even
something strictly simple like that let
alone other kinds of domains like
speaking languages or driving cars all
these other things that of course garry
kasparov could do effortlessly
so instead of that we think about
intelligence in the framework of what's
called reinforcement learning so I'm
just going to illustrate what the main
basic parts of that in this little
cartoon diagram because it's important
for what I'm going to show next in terms
of the videos of the of them of the
algorithms working so you start off with
your agent system represented by this
little humanoid character and that agent
finds itself in an environment which
could be virtual or real world if it's
real-world the agent will probably be a
robot if it's virtual the agent will be
an avatar and the agent has some kind of
goal that has been given to that is
trying to achieve in that environment
and the agent only interacts with the
environment in two ways one is that it
gets observations through its sensory
apparatus observations about the world
and we mostly use vision at the moment
but we're also looking to use other
sensory modalities soon and those
observations are always incomplete and
noisy so you never get full information
about the world unlike say a game of
chess where it's a perfect state
information you see everything that's in
the game world in in the real world of
course you don't get to see all the
information and that one of the jobs of
the agent system is to build a
a model as possible of the environment
out there based solely on these noisy
incomplete observations and the agent is
doing this in real time these these
observations are coming in every time
step and is then the agent is
continually updating its model of the
world based on this new evidence that it
gets and the second job of the agent is
to then pick what action it should take
what's the best action it can take in
that particular moment in time that will
guess best get it towards its goal from
the current situation that it finds
itself in and once it's decided what
that action should be it outputs that
action that action gets executed and
that then may drive a change in the
environment which will then drive a new
observation and this goes round in a
endless sort of cycle now although this
diagram is a very simple to sort of
explain actually it hides an incredible
amount of complexity so we know that if
you could solve all the problems behind
the underlie this diagram this
representation then that would be enough
for true artificial intelligence and we
know that because this is the way that
biological systems learn including
humans and most mammals and in fact in
humans it's the dopamine system that
implements a form of reinforcement
learning so we go we went on to test
these kinds of systems and actually we
chose to test the intelligence of our
systems on computer games now a true
thinking machine we believe would have
to be embedded in a sensory motor data
stream you can't have true intelligence
and true thinking unless you have the
ability to affect the world that you're
in and the ability to sense that world
and and so usually so this is called
embodied cognition and usually when
people subscribe to this view of AI they
normally start working on robots real
robots based in obviously in real world
environments but robots are very tricky
to use they're very expensive they're
very slow and they break down so if you
talk to anyone who's
used all to try to develop on robots
your your here a lot of of the work
actually goes into fixing the mechanics
of the robots the motors and the sensors
and so on and actually we didn't want to
be distracted by that we wanted to focus
on the intelligence algorithms
themselves so what we decided to use was
video games in the first instance and of
course it's a little bit to do with my
background where it came in useful here
in video games and use it and repurpose
the games as a platform for testing the
intelligence and the capabilities of our
AI algorithms now games are really good
because obviously you can run them in
the cloud you can run them much faster
than real time you can run millions of
experiments in parallel and it's very
easy to measure progress because most
games fortunately have game scores so
you can see very conveniently if your
algorithmic tweaks are gaining you an
advantage and whether you're heading in
the right direction based on the
performance in those environments and
that's something that's very important
especially for a very long term mission
like we have and very ambitious mission
is to be able to break down an ambitious
mission into smaller chunks that are
very easy to measure the progress on the
other key thing about games is that
obviously they were designed by other
people and other other engineering teams
and they weren't designed specifically
for AI testing and so what that means is
that you have to deal with all kinds of
interesting problems that you would
never have dealt with designed yourself
as an AI designer and I think that's
actually makes sure that there isn't any
bias in the types of problems that you
apply your AI to so one of the big
problems of in AI research that has been
over the last few decades is that
generally speaking is the AI designers
that also design the problems and
subconsciously whether you like it or
not you end up designing problems that
you know your AI algorithms are well
suited to so what we started off with
was actually atari games from the 80s
which were really the first iconic
platform that had a lot of very popular
challenging games on it and we decided
to start with that and what we did is we
started with an open-source emulator for
atari games and we souped it up and made
it more robust and made it run faster
and then we plugged it in our AI
algorithms into this system now I'm
going to show you a couple of videos of
the AI system working and then but
before I do that I just wanted to
explain to you what it is you're going
to see so the AI system here only gets
the raw pixels as inputs so it's almost
as if we set up a video camera observing
the screen and the only information that
it gets is the raw pixels so it doesn't
know anything about what it's
controlling it doesn't know what the aim
of the game is it doesn't know how to
get points all it's been told is that it
needs to this goal is to maximize the
score everything else is learned from
scratch and then there's the sort of
generality component comes in again
where we require a single system to play
all the different games out of the box
and there's obviously dozens and dozens
of very very different Atari games so
the first thing you're going to show you
is space invaders probably the most
iconic game that they're you know
there's ever been and I'm going to show
you sort of two parts of this video so
in the beginning as I roll the video now
you know you'll see what the agent looks
like when it first encounters this
environment and it's controlling the
rocket at the bottom of this screen
obviously it's trying actions randomly
because it has no idea what it's
supposed to be doing and it loses its
three lives almost immediately now if
you leave the machine training overnight
you come back the next day the the
machine now is superhuman at at the at
the at the game so every single shot it
it fires hit something it can't be
killed anymore it's worked out that the
pink mothership at the top of the screen
is worth a lot of points it does these
amazing accurate shots and you can see
that the model it's built of the world
is is extremely accurate so those of you
play space invaders back in the 80s
we'll remember that as there's less of
them they get faster if you just watch
the last shot your
see that it sort of predicted where
where that is going to where where that
term space invader is going to end up
and far as the shortest shot ahead of
time so I'm going to show you a second
video now which is the game of breakout
it's my favorite video where I'm going
to show a few more gradations of the
agent getting better and more capable so
in this game the agent is controlling
the the pink baton ball and the aim of
the game is to break through this
rainbow colored brick wall brick by
brick so to start off with after 100
games the the AI system has you know
it's not very good you can see it's
missing the ball most of the time but
you can see maybe you can convince
yourself it's starting to get the hang
of the idea that it should be moving the
back towards the ball now after 300
games you can see that the the system
has now got pretty much as good as any
human can play this and almost always
gets the ball back even when it's coming
back at very vertical angles so we
thought that was pretty cool but we
thought well what would happen if we
left the agent running for longer and
played another 200 games and then this
unexpected thing happened it discovered
the optimal strategy was to dig a tunnel
round the side and send the ball you
know round the back of the wall and you
know it's doing that again with sort of
superhuman accuracy in terms of the
motor control there and and that
strategy and one of the funny things is
is that although the researchers on that
are amazing programmers and and and
engineers they're not so good at playing
Atari game so they didn't actually know
about that strategy so it's I think you
know an example of a system that you've
created actually teaching you something
which was quite a watershed moment for
us so if you entered in that work we
this was then fully published in nature
and the front cover earlier this year
and we actually even released the code
as well so you can you can have a look
at that and play with that yourselves so
now we're moving on to 3d games go robot
simulators and of course we are
interested in robots but as a develop
application rather than as a development
platform now I'll just show you one
thing on the 3d stuff
so we'll have a lot more announcements
new announcements to make in the next
year but we show this sort of run this
little video of the same agent that you
saw playing the Atari games actually now
driving a racing car around a track in a
3d game so again the only inputs here
are the pixels the raw pixels and the co
steering wheel controls and it's learnt
just from war experience driving the car
around how to drive and even do things
like it's overtaking the other cars that
sort of 200 kilometers an hour and again
just from the raw pixel data so we're
now moving towards much more advanced 3d
environments where we're looking at maze
problems and all kinds of much more
complex paths finding problems now I
spoke about neuroscience at the
beginning of the talk and just want to
come back and touch on that now so we
talked a lot about the AI that we build
it the mind as being neuroscience
inspired and in fact many of the
research areas that we're looking at now
we are looking to neuroscience very
closely for inspiration about four new
types of algorithms as to how the brain
works so we're looking at memory
attention concepts planning navigation
and imagination now because this is a
you know each one of those areas would
probably need a whole talk to to sort of
get into so I'm just going to focus on
imagination because I think that's most
relevant for the audience here and
there's also what I did for my PhD now
it turns out that imagination is quite
dependent on an area of the brain called
the hippocampus which is actually here
this area in pink here at the centre of
your brain in this in this diagram of
the human brain
now the hippocampus it's very important
right there's quite a small part of the
brain small brain region but it's very
critical brain region and it's been
known for you know more than 50 years
now that if you damage the hippocampus
then you how you become a music so it's
well known that the hippocampus is vital
for episodic memory but what wasn't
known was what else was the hippocampus
useful for
for example was it involved with
imagination now I suspected that it
might might be because when I started
reading the literature on memory and
hippocampus when I started my PhD I sort
of came across this literature that was
talking about memory as being a
reconstructive process rather than like
something like a videotape so and that's
actually the way that memory works when
if you remember this lecture tomorrow it
won't it's not kind of like a store like
a videotape somewhere in your mind
actually you will be combining it from
all sorts of components of things and
experiences that you've had before other
lectures perhaps other visits to the
British Museum as well as specific
pieces of content that are to do with
this evening specifically and what your
brain does in the hippocampus is
involved with is reconstructing that
pulling all those parts together into a
coherent whole which then is recognized
by the rest of your brain as actually an
episodic memory so I was thinking well
if memory works as a reconstructive
process then if we think about
imagination as being a similar process
but in this case it's a constructive
process if we think of memory as trying
to put your components that you have
together in a way that your brain thinks
looks and judges as familiar perhaps
creativity's that is the converse of
that you're still bringing together
those components but now you're trying
to create something novel that actually
your brain judges as unfamiliar so I was
thinking well if memory is heavily
depend on the hippocampus then maybe
imagination is also a very heavily
dependent on the same brain structure
and the same processes so we decided to
test this was actually by getting going
around the country to interview patients
who had damage to the hippocampus but
only the hippocampus and there's very
rare sorts of diseases that cause that
although things like Alzheimer's
actually do attack the hippocampus but
also other brain structures but what we
needed were patients that had only
specific damage only to this one brain
region and we tested those patients on
their imaginative abilities rather than
their episodic memory and what we did is
gave them fairly a kind of simple
imaginative task we
given word cues like the following
imagine you're lying on a white sandy
beach in a beautiful tropical Bay
describing as much detail as you can
what you can see and hear and experience
around you and what happened was is when
we compared and broke down their
descriptions we scored it in a very
complex scoring system to break down how
rich that description was and we
compared it to age and educated and IQ
matched control subjects so they were
matched in every way except obviously
they had intact and healthy hippocampus
'as we found that on our richness
measure or exponential index measure
that the imagined scenes that the
hippocampal patients were describing
were hugely impoverished compared to the
healthy controls and you can see that in
these two than if you can see this laser
pointer in these two bar charts so on
the left hand side here is the patient's
the five patients and then here are the
ten match controls to these patients and
you can see this is the sort of richness
index if you like of the described scene
and you can see that the patients are
massively deficient compared to the two
compared to the controls so so it seems
indeed that the hippocampus is very
important for imagining the future and
actually the New Scientist reported on
this work and it became quite a big
study that was also listed in Sciences
as one of the big breakthroughs of 2007
and the New Scientist had quite a nice
headline talking about hippocampal
patients being stuck in the present so
the idea was that you know that we know
they can't remember the past very well
and now it turns out they can't imagine
the future either so but yet if you were
to talk to them they seem you know for a
few minutes they would seem completely
normal to you and you'd be able to
converse with them completely normally
because they're processing the present
in the same way that a healthy person
would so we then then followed this up
in fMRI and we found out of course the
hippocampus doesn't support imagination
on its own it's part of a it's a
critical Court sort of core part of
much larger brain network that includes
all sorts of other brain regions from
the retro spindle to the medial frontal
cortex to the medial temporal lobe
lateral temporal cortex and parietal
cortex so all these regions reliably
come on when you scan somebody in the
brain scanner and you get them to
imagine scenes and the this network is
the imagination network if you like so
they're much more recently I was
thinking well okay so that so this is
how humans imagined but what about
animals can they imagine as well for
example can a rat imagine we know again
we know that rats have memory very good
memory in fact but can they do things
like imagine the future so before I just
show you the study that we did to
investigate that I just need to take you
through a couple of things about that we
know about rats and we know that rats
can do so the first thing to tell you
about is play cells now play cells or
you can really think of them as the GPS
coordinates in a rat's brain about where
they are so if we imagine a box that
they're at might be in a box so here
we're looking top down on this
environment then the rat might be
roaming around this box and you know
these experiments you record directly
from the rats brain while they're
roaming around and what you find is is
that cells in the hippocampus fire in
specific places in the environment so
for example a cell at cell a might fire
only when the rat is traversing through
this particular part of the box
environment
conversely cell B might only fire in
another part of the environment now the
amazing person who discovered this John
Okeefe who discovered these place cells
in the 70s just around the corner at UCL
won the Nobel Prize for this last year
and I was lucky enough to have him as my
on my viper committee for my PhD so I
got to know him well and the entire rat
literature very well and what I started
thinking about is since that discovery
of play cells people have found that
actually
sequences of play cells fire in in kind
of sequence when a rat moves through an
environment so for example let's take a
new environment here a linear track so
this is like a linear box and the rats
moving form from left to right here and
what you find if you record from the
brains of these rats is that play cells
will fire in order a b c and d depending
mimicking the way and matching the way
that the rat is moving through that
environment and in the 90's other
people's found that when they recorded
from the brains of these rats while they
were asleep after they had walked around
and navigated in one of these maze like
environments that the rats would replay
the trajectories they'd experienced in
their wake session before so you could
you could really think about this as
rats dreaming so they would replay this
trajectory of ABCD but now this would be
just they would be sleeping soundly and
it will be just their their brains
replaying this and what's interesting is
that the brain of these rats actually
replay these trajectories an order of
magnitude faster than they actually
experienced it in real life so if you
think about dreaming as maybe helping
the rats learn about the environments
that in then they're they're actually
learning from this much more efficiently
than they can experience it when they're
awake so that's shows that rats have
memory and perhaps they dream but it's
not showing that they actually imagined
new experiences that they have an
experience while they're awake so we
wanted to show that unequivocally and
recently we published a study with some
colleagues of mine at UCL Annie life
that I think unequivocally shows that
rats do imagine so we designed this
simple but I think quite elegant design
to test this hypothesis out so what we
had here is a teammate's this time so
again we're looking top-down on the on
the rat environment and the T maze has a
barrier so and this barrier here stops
the rat
that starts off in the stem of the
t-maze and it stops the rat moving to
the arms of the t-maze but it's see
through the barrier so the rat can see
past to the arms and see what's on the
arms so the rat is initially in the
first session running up and down the
stem of the T mate and what we do to
make the rat really interested in the
arms is we put some food
a rice pellet on one of the arms here
and depicted by this yellow dot and on
the right hand arm and the rat can see
this when it gets to the barrier but it
can't reach the right pellet so
obviously it's very motivated to think
about to try and get the right pellet
but it can't get past the barrier so
then after it's experience that
environment for a while we let the rat
go to sleep and that where of course
we're recording from the rats brain
while this is going on and then we wake
the rat up again and now we put it back
in the environment but this time we
remove that barrier so now it's free to
run around the whole teammate so it does
that happily it moves around the the the
stem and the arms both the left arm and
the right arm and it fully explores this
whole environment so obviously as I've
just told you with the play cells what
we can do is we find that there are play
cells let's say cell a and cell D that
fire on the arm section of the maze now
what we can do is then go back to look
at the data we collected when the rat
was asleep and see if the rat was
imagining about those trajectories
towards the rice pellet before it ever
had experienced it in reality so don't
forget when it was sleeping it the rat
had never experienced walking on this or
it had only seen that all and what
happens is we find our conjecture what
sort of proven that actually you get we
find what if we go back and analyze the
sleep data you get this replay or pre
play if you like of this trajectory ABCD
and what's more is this is not just
random pre play you actually get more
significantly more pre play to the right
hand arm
then to the left hand on which is
exactly what you would expect if it's
behaviorally consequential right so you
can I mean of course this is
anthropomorphizing the rat but you could
imagine the rats really wanting to get
to that rice pellet and is imagining
plans of how could it get there by
almost imagining yourself walking to the
right pillar and then eating it and so
and then it's dreaming about it imagine
experiences right so so and that's
really what's going on here I think
and of course we're now going to look
into this further we have a number of
plans to look at follow-on studies from
this with more complex environments so
you know humans imagine rats imagine so
what about machines so this is something
that's key imagination to planning for
the future making plans good plans about
the future so this is obviously
something that we also want our machines
to be able to do so you know I've
entitled this slide to do Androids Dream
of Electric Sheep which is of course is
a reference to philip k dick famous book
and one of my frame one of my favorite
films Blade Runner and and this is
really I'm just going to give you a very
short excerpt here with this video of
which is little bit of an insight into
the mind of the machine that you saw
earlier playing space invaders so I told
you though that one of the purposes of
the agent system is to build a model of
the world so it can predict the future
of what's going to happen in that game
world and here what I'm going to show in
this sort of 10-second video is the
Machine getting an initial input from
space invaders like this this is the
game position and then freely imagining
or dreaming about what might happen over
the next times to ten seconds so you can
see it's dream that moving it's it's the
rocket and it's really about getting
points and shooting some of the space
invaders now it's quite fuzzy because
there's uncertainty about what might
happen in the world it's all
probabilistic so it's not certain as
seeing an actual screen but it's the
beginnings I think of imagination based
planning now I'm just going to end by
talking a little bit about so that's
imagination so once you start thinking
well could machines have imagination
what about creativity and something I
get asked about all the time
and of course is very relevant to a lot
of the work that people in this room do
and you know I think we're a long way
away from machines being truly creative
but I don't think it's impossible and I
think that when we start to understand
what this process is this mysterious
process for creativity is I think it
will become actually more obvious how to
implement that in an algorithm so I just
want to show a couple of little hints of
things that might surprise you so let's
just take a picture of the British
Museum the front of this building and if
we then say to the Machine and this is a
new type of algorithm that was actually
first very recently invented at Max
Planck Institute in Germany and then
we've implemented our own version of
this internally and what you can do is
you can give it a artistic picture like
this van Gogh picture and say you want
it to you want V that photo redrawn in
the style of Van Gogh right and and
actually so you ends up with outputs
that are like this where you can
actually it's not ready yet to be hung
in the Louvre but you can sort of start
thinking it's pretty surprising when I
saw these things like how a coherent the
output can be and then you know we can
look at other examples so actually this
is a concert piece of concept art for a
new Google campus that's being built in
in Silicon Valley and we give it a
Seurat painting and then we ask it to
output it as one of my favorite ones and
it you know it produces pretty good
version of the of the original but in in
the style of surround and this isn't
true creativity right in some senses as
a parlor trick because what we're doing
here is deconstructing the the features
of both the original photo and the the
painting and then we're swapping those
features over writing of the photo
features with the painting features and
that gives this this these kinds of
outputs but the surprising thing here is
that there isn't much sort of what you
would regard as creativity here and yet
you get these kind of very interesting
outputs
so it may be that creativity isn't as
mysterious as it seems to us when we
ultimately find out what it is now I'm
just going to end by talking a little
bit about the bigger picture and sort of
the impact that AI might have in the
future and so you know I think some of
the big problems that are facing us as a
society are information overload and
system complexity so you know everywhere
we go now where daily use by information
so things like obviously genomics big
data in general but in the world of TV
you know entertainment I mean there's so
many TV channels now and modes of
watching things how can you really find
what it is that you're interested in and
personalization is one kind of
technology that might help but it
doesn't really work because it's really
based at the moment on quite primitive
sort of wisdom of the crowds
collaborative filtering technology and
that doesn't give you unique
recommendations that are unique to your
what I would call longtail of interests
and then in terms of system complexity
the kinds of systems we would like to
master you know climate disease energy
macroeconomics even particle physics are
becoming so complex now that even teams
of the what of the best and brightest
human experts are having difficulty
comprehending the implications of these
systems and actually making useful
predictions about them so I think
solving intelligent solving AI is
potentially a kind of meta solution to
all these problems if we can solve
intelligence then maybe we can use it to
help us as human experts get a better
handle on all these other systems and my
dream really the thing I'd like to use
general AI for is to build AI scientists
or to make a I assisted science possible
and of course if we have something this
powerful then obviously we need to think
about the ethics of that the use of it
and as with all new powerful
technologies and I think AI is no
different from many other technologies
in the past in this regard we have to be
very cognizant about using these
technologies ethically and responsibly
and although human-level AI I think
general AI is there many decades away I
think we should start the debate now and
indeed that's what we're doing both with
our own internal
ethics committees but also by supporting
academic work and academic conferences
on these topics and then finally with a
nod to neuroscience I think building AI
actually in this way this neuroscience
inspired way help us better understand
the mysteries and the workings of our
own minds and I think in in the future
you know I think we're on part of the
journey we're on is that as we try to
distill intelligence into an algorithmic
construct if we then compare that with
the capabilities of the human mind I
think we'll better understand about
what's unique and special about our own
minds like dreaming creativity and
perhaps even the great consciousness
question and as Fineman said one of my
all-time scientific heroes what I cannot
build I do not truly understand thanks
for listening we're welcome
take it forward that was brilliant
if we get the lights up I'm going to ask
one question but not hog the limelight
here and I'll hand over to the audience
we're gonna have 20 minutes so how about
have a little pause have a think about
what you want to ask Demick is there
probably provoked in so much kind of
thinking and what one question I've got
very simple one actually is if you what
I was amazed by was that what you what
you details your 20 year plan you know
get your chest skills sorted you know in
terms of those virtual environments in
gaming then then you needed the new but
that was the first 20 years and you just
talked about decades away because I
think people are pretty obsessed with
yeah the taking that raw data in
building the picture of the environment
where we're at Atari games I knew that
breakout trick but anyway we're at Atari
games and then the other end of the
spectrum is the AI scientists taking Roy
what some just give us a sense in in the
generation you're real yeah
what's a realistic moon-landing in your
terms yeah
no one is it I touched on some of those
things in that neuroscience slide of the
things of big things I think are
important to solve that beyond like the
Atari games of course we're sort of on
the first rung of the ladder there the
Atari thing was significant because it
was the first time anyone built at what
we call an end-to-end agent so something
that took true war data
yeah and then a decision just ended that
in one big cycle obviously I think the
next big breakthroughs will be can it
really learn abstract concepts and go
beyond just perceptual inputs and have a
real underlying understanding of the
semantics of the world it finds itself
in so that's I think you know for us is
our big kind of and Phi mean is this
gonna be exponential like the way
computers developed we ogum in 20 years
be bowled over by the speed of
progression I think it's hot because
we've only got one of you and you're not
going to be here forever so I've got
that with I want to know how much we can
get yeah I mean I think it's hard to
predict because you know we need at
least a dozen really huge breakthroughs
and I think to get all that way and and
and research breakthroughs are
notoriously hard to put in the timescale
north so I think we'll have you know
several very surprising things over
few years but you know as to how far
we'll get all the way I think it's too
hard to say from here you know
personalized timescales for that
brilliant I'm going to open it up
because it's easy for me I could be here
all night but why we start up there
we'll get a mic to you that gentleman
there with me then we'll come down to
the front I don't know many mics we've
got going Tim Marshall if the squeamish
will just close their eyes for a second
a few weeks ago I was at a conference
where a robot was performing a prostate
operation more than just performing the
operation it could actually understand
the tumor and make a decision whether to
proceed or not today we've seen in the
news the challenges of providing health
care where do you think what role do you
think AI can play in diagnosis and
treatment in health because the way we
practice medicine at the moment is a
19th century paradigm so I'd be
interested in your thoughts on that yeah
it's great actually a health care is
actually one of the main application
areas were focusing on first I think we
could probably revolutionize the sort of
quality of the care and the efficiency
of it you know as you say we're still
using kind of 19th century methods and I
think having this sort of latest
information available in a digestible
actionable way to surgeons and GPS and
so on you know I think will must really
help that whole you know the whole
healthcare space so it's something we're
looking to get heavily involved with in
the next few years why did you decide to
publish the code and were you ever
worried or concerns
yeah I mean we try to be as open as
possible about what we're doing so we
generally publish almost everything that
we do and where we can we do open source
things as well so actually our neural
network library is called torch that we
build our algorithm the top of there
that's open source and we felt and there
was a demand for some of the nature
reviewers and editors that you know be
nice if we could release our code so we
thought about it and we decided in that
case that was fine but you know that may
not always be the case for the stuff we
do and once you have to consider that on
a case-by-case basis but in general
where we can we like to engage and
support the general academic community
and we think it's important that
knowledge is shared and I think that's
the way that humanity can advance as
quickly as possible the second really
you're you're one of the largest brains
in the planet and Google is now brought
to you and I'm going to ask you that
question which I'm sure you're expecting
the Stephen Hawking thing then the
concern about AI that once you have the
genie out of the bottle and we're all
[ __ ] I know and so making 40 buddy
what he would what you're doing dodging
go for it deficit this is a this is the
regular media yes sure I mean look I
I've actually spoken i had a long chat
with stephen hawking about this you know
a few months ago and i think was the guy
well he was I think he was very
enjoyable and I think he we spent hours
together we only spent half an hour but
he was he had so many questions and I
think he was quite reassured after we
talked about how we were we would
specifically were approaching it and I
think look you know there are big big
issues here very big issues about
autonomous learning systems what goal
should we give them what value system
should we give them how can we make sure
that those exactly what we want and
there are very tough pieces of research
that need to be done there hasn't been
much work done in that area yet partly
because there been no systems to really
try this out on so
all been thought experiments and I think
if you do you know mostly the people
thinking about this and worrying about
this to that extent are not in the AI
field right there either philosophers or
their other very famous scientists or or
industrialists but not actually working
on AI themselves and if they were
working I think they would see that the
problems are much more prosaic at the
moment and it's easy I think to get
carried away with science fiction
scenarios that are you know many decades
away my I have confidence that as we get
bill more powerful systems we'll have
much better ideas about answers to these
questions that I just talked about value
systems and so on and you know
mathematical proofs of it and periodical
work that will allow us to have a much
better idea of how to keep these systems
on the control well I'm pleased to see
that you've got the the Ethics Committee
they're on board and you're thinking
about these issued issues but you have
taken the Yankee dollar and I am worried
about this because you're so smart and I
hope that everything you do actually
improves the society rather than kills
us off ABS well so do i but better you
know I think AI you know could be the
greatest thing for Humanity in the sense
of if we build it right will solve all
these big issues that point do expect
corporate but corporate responsibility
versus your not your personal with its
shine through I think that's a big one
isn't it in terms of yeah where power
lies into Sasha I mean I should probably
make you know to say a little bit about
that so obviously we spend a long time
doing due diligence ourselves on Google
right and we had a lot of other options
and clearly stay independent and we
decided to join forces with them partly
because the people high up at Google
agreed with things like the ethics
committee and thought it was a good idea
that govern the use of the technology of
deepmind technology we've already out
ruled out things obvious things like
military or intelligence applications so
you know by default deep mind stuff
doesn't cannot be used for those things
and then obviously we you know we've had
our inaugural meeting of the committee
ethics committee there are very big
luminaries on that many of whom are some
of the people that you've mentioned who
are worried about this stuff not just
the people who think positively about it
and a big part of that actually because
it you know we are decades of
is to just start educating everyone on
what the real issues are and separate
sort of fact from science fiction and I
think that's the first starting point
and then we can actually get to the hub
of the really core technical difficult
questions there are and there are some
but I'm very confident if we apply
enough brainpower on to it with enough
time we'll solve those problems right
okay um you've been in Google now for
about a year
can you can you give us a couple of
examples or or anecdotes about how deep
mind has changed the company taken over
some processes changed the way the
company works or going forward and just
to tag onto the ethics committee why
haven't you publicized or published
who's who's on it so first question is
um please say almost nothing's changed
and that's the whole point of it that
was one of the main agreements so it's
we are you know our headquarters is
still in the UK and green ground Kings
Cross we've built invested in the
research team there so the whole of the
miners still UK side and you know we're
variant that we work as a kind of
semi-autonomous type of unit the plus
sides are the amount compute power
obviously we have access to has really
accelerated our progress and obviously
the other resources they do I'm sorry I
meant the other way around how is deep
mind affected Google as a company I see
well so that's harder to say I mean
Google's very big but I think that we
have actually affected it in some senses
the way that some other parts of Google
research do their work so there's
actually thousands of people in Google
research and there's thousands people
working on machine learning but we we
sort of have a more coherent specific
mission than the more applied machine
learning against done elsewhere in
Google so I think we bring we bring
together a kind of longer-term research
focus that I think maybe Google wants
more of now and that's requires quite
different organizational structures and
management processes which you know some
of some of which is being adopted over
in Mountain View in Silicon Valley now
so your second question was about the
why don't we publicize stuff well
firstly
you know that we're very early days and
there's a lot of scrutiny on this and
there's nothing at the moment it's about
simply about educating people or getting
everyone up to speed with the issues
once you start making things public then
immediately that changes that can change
the debate and I wanted to have a period
of sort of quiet behind-the-scenes calm
calm collected debate before we
additionally brought on ourselves this
additional sort of public scrutiny so at
some point I think we will announce who
you know these people are and also a
little bit about what the issues are
that are being discussed
having said that we already do lots of
public things so there was a big
conference in Puerto Rico that was
talking about AI ethics and safety
there's another one at U New York
University in January that we're
sponsoring and I'm keynoting and on a
program committee all along with
Facebook the heads of AI is there and
Microsoft and some of the other
companies so I think probably the next
stage next year would be to create a
cross industry panel and bring together
all the big companies and academic labs
that are working on this in addition to
our own internal committee
okay let's crack through a few more
we've got about ten minutes so I think
someone's got a mic here there and they
will want it right thank you yes that
was a billion presentation thank you
very much for that I'm what an engineer
I'm now a slightly ID'd academic we work
on we've done general video gaming
machines so I appreciate that very much
but when you go the next stage up to
imagination then there must be so many
individual random coordinates if you
like because I think we all imagined
differently that you'll spend in an
infinite amount of time trying to
analyze these to actually make machines
if you like imagine in planned fashion
so how do you how do you cope with this
these coordinates you can't I've built
as well because a lot of the audience
room for the television audience here
can see and I suspect there was a bit of
a shudder around East kidding he the
creative story which is yeah that's a
bit clunky we should admit it you know
kind of merge universe
versus you know when the first director
yeah when the first writer cut when
those the invert the points in the
environment that
choices becomes right I mean I think
financial versus a Space Invaders
exactly it's like the rice on the chess
board yeah so I think I think most
people's jobs in here a safe CEO is
quite her so so relief I don't think
there's going to be any directors you
know directing something you know the
quality of Ridley Scott or something for
you know that's pretty going to be one
of the if ever one of the last things
that that computer will be able to do so
we are talking about very constrained
things where you know that's a very
difficult thing that humans are course
do better than the way better than
computers is we you know they can have
this rudimentary kind of brute force
imagination but one of the big things
that humans do is is if they have
aesthetic judgment right they know that
not all piles are equal and and some of
them are likely to be more fruitful than
others even if you compare chess
grandmaster playing chess compared to a
computer they you know computer might
look at millions of moves to make that
one decision whereas a chess grant must
only look at a few hundred but judicial
ones and they in some sense our brains
even filter out our low-level part brain
or any of the kind of moves or
trajectories that are not going to yield
anything useful and you know that we
know do that filtrate are you working on
me or we are I mean work on that filter
a part of that is is to do with how well
you model the world that you're in so if
you're better at modeling the world then
what that means is you should make
better predictions about what are going
to be useful things to spend your
compute time imagining or thinking about
and at the moment we you know we're
still very early stages of that very
baby
hi David Abraham from channel 4 you
touched on and the challenge of how many
choices people have in entertainment and
something that we in our industry is
spending a lot of time thinking about
are you working more specifically on the
area of recommendation engines and are
you going to be as it were capturing the
power of that algorithm on behalf of
Google yeah we are looking at
recommendation systems and
you know in all forms actually all sorts
of forms and I think is a very
interesting area and it's something that
our technology is quite quite sort of
applicable to again it's about you know
can you model user journeys and
trajectories through things and in a way
that you know then delivers much more
compelling content or recommendations
and I think you know the current systems
we have and not good enough and you know
we're experimenting that again we don't
we're quite early days with that and
we're looking at that for things both
internally at Google and external
probably do see external because I think
that we deeply intriguing to a number of
us in the room who are working in the
media business about how to serve up
stuff in a world where choices yes
floated yeah and the general application
of that a few years or you know you
think would be i noticing stuff products
coming I think maybe you might be the
wrong word forget my ass but systems by
which the likes of channel for the BBC
other broadcasts in the room independent
companies can serve their content up
using that's not far away yeah I think
in the next couple years you'll start
seeing under the hood
algorithms helping the these kinds of
recommendation systems and then maybe
four or five years out actual hope
totally new systems that you might
interact with in a different way too we
do now that's nice yeah probably got
with coming towards the last few but
we'll get through as many as I can
hi dungeon tool from IBM I think we're
one of the other big investors in AI and
I liked your comments around the big
breakthroughs it probably takes more
than one player to get us to to the
future space I had a couple of questions
in treatment in your talk one was go so
so years ago I think there was a big
effort around going it was it was the
big one that was hard for computers to
solve it might be a bit esoteric for
this audience and then the second
question just to bring us to the point
is for RTS how can a I be used not to
supplant creativity but to enhance and
support it and allows to do more
creative things as humans not as
computers to equipment on the first one
because you might wanna do that
afterwards and it's really yeah so so go
said go for those you don't know is it
is an oriental board game which is the
probably most complex game there
it's what they play in China and Japan
instead of an career instead of chess
and one reason it's been so hard for
computers to crack is that the branching
factor the number of choices you have in
each booth is the order of a hundred
whereas in chess it's more like 20 so as
you start planning that branching factor
explodes so if you're going to do in a
brute-force way they weren't enough I
think atoms in the universe to describe
how many go positions there are for
example are you your bet you're good at
go on here I'm reasonably good at go
where you will choke where are you world
champion that girl champion no but but
but and then the second problem is that
in chess because chess is a very
materialistic game so the queen is worth
more than a rook and so on it's quite
easy to hand program an evaluation
function to tell you whether your
program is winning or losing or how well
it's doing in that position whereas in
go all the pieces are worth the same
they're just there's just one piece and
so whether you're winning or not is much
more about the overall pattern of the
board so it's a much more beautiful game
in some sense very aesthetically
pleasing but it's much harder to hand
code an evaluation function so yeah we
have we're going to have some very big
announcements to make on go I mean it's
sort of been the holy grail for the AI
research communities for the last 20
years since the blue actually beat
Kasparov sorry yeah short so yeah and
then so then then the the last question
was on automated rate so that's it for
this audience oh that's really that's
really the same thing I'm thinking about
in science too right and and with
doctors and with while reading there's
AI surfacing the right information for
you for you in a much more digestible
way so you can just leverage that for
whatever is in the world immediate I
mean we took the recommendation area is
there anything else in your head you
might springs to mind in terms of the
creative process that creates the media
I think there's a lot tougher so I think
recommendation is the obvious one we are
looking at things like music which is
kind of more constrained domain for
computer than visuals I mean which is
incredibly hard right and there's some
very interesting work being done in
music music composition music analysis
which i think is pretty
promising so I would imagine that would
be the next place very good I'm going to
take three more because we're really
running at a time I'm sorry because we
could just keep going all night here
take gentlemen here
has anyone got a microphone on them
because we'll just get the nice
gentleman here anyone the back want to
have a because I've been very front
focus at the dental on the Enduro right
in the back there
honey coladas are from IBM we've been
sheep from the search of pain and
pleasure during our all cultural history
and its shaped the way that we're
thinking and we are behaving how can you
teach pain and pleasure to a machine
well one question is whether we whether
we need to but also or whether we should
and but there is although this speaks to
this idea actually that we look at
internally of intrinsic motivation we
call it so you know there are emotions
and other things that drive human
behavior not just external rewards so
you know at the moment our machines
don't have anything like that but maybe
to do more complex tasks or you know
we're the moment working in game worlds
where there is conveniently a scorer
most most of the time but even if you
start going to more complex games
open-ended things like minecraft now
there is a score anymore right so how
are you going to decide what you should
do what is what's useful what's good
that you're making progress and I'm
talking about the agent system here so
and of course that's more like the real
world for us as as humans and yet
somehow we have our own internal drives
probably there have been evolved to that
helped influence our behavior so I think
it's interesting to think about and you
know we have neuroscientist or experts
in these areas who work with us as
consultants and it's something I'm very
fascinated by but you know we don't have
a definite answer on that yet thank you
right two more so we'll check the gentle
at the back I think east someone still
want a question about I got a hand up
there yes there is right the back there
I'll just fill and then we'll take the
gentleman the red as the last question
no pressure
my my question leads on quite well from
the last actually I was thinking have
you thought about general
the goals so you talked about how that
the you have a observations and you have
actions that you take but presumably you
define the goal then you tell the system
how to measure its goals and if we're
thinking about AI is something which is
a servant to to human intelligence then
have you thought about AI which can
derive its goals from the environment
can can also and also as humans we
segment our goals we might have life
goals but we focus on sub goals to get
there and also not just and I'm sort of
imagining a human saying to a system can
you help me with this and that and the
AI being able to derive its goal from
the things that it hears but also going
further than that being able to derive
goals before they're specifically
instructed so being able to anticipate
goals that people might want out of AI
so nice cook at a high school that's
right
I mean that's very few no that's a great
question and actually it's a fascinating
research areas can the machines learn
their own goals but through observation
of you know learn what it is you like
through observing you for example right
and then trying to you know maybe even
be able to preemptively guess what it is
that you need before you even ask for it
so I think you know those systems are
very interesting I mean even there you
would still have some kind of top-level
goal which is to satisfy the user right
although it may learn what the sub goals
are and that's another very active area
of research is how do you break down a
large goal in ters into automatically
into sub goals and of course that's
something our minds do effortlessly you
know if you're going to plan to you know
a trip to Paris from here your brain is
not going to plan over your muscle fibre
movements all the way from here to Paris
right it's but but yet that's how
robotics works in them and like they
have known defining of hierarchy well
you're a train's actually going to do is
like you know at high level you need to
get to the Eurostar terminal and then
take a train there and so on and then
only at the point where you get up off
that chair does your brain then go and
unpack the muscle fiber movement of get
you know get up off a chair and and walk
so whereas at the moment because we
Devin solve this problem of
automatically
generating sub-goals a robot for example
trying to do that task would have to
plan over the primitive action movements
all the way to Paris and of courses is
not feasible and therefore not tractable
because it ends up becoming you know
speak to the other gentleman's question
about you imagine all those paths from
here are muscle muscle fiber movements
there's an infinite there's basically
infinite number of them so so we need
that's one of the key things we need to
solve is the sub goal problem the last
question open them like sorry let's get
that across maqam power broadcast
engineer following off from an earlier
one and your list of memory navigation
imagination etc you didn't have emotions
and as we're going to be dealing with
and interacting with humans how
explosive is that with your conflicts of
ethics and parameters yeah I mean again
this this relates to the question our
gentlemen down here about emotions we
currently you know there is no
equivalent of that in our systems but if
you think of inch in emotions and
pulleys is too simplistic but part of
emotions are internal drives give us
internal drives then that's something we
do need to explore and try and work out
what ones might be needed and it might
be we need similar ones so that these
systems can empathize with humans you
know obviously there's a great channel
for series I think the people some
people within the audience of humans
which I really love and that that's
interesting you know they're trying to
empathize with the humans that they
serve alternatively you might want to
have systems that have no a very
different types of drives that help them
be complimentary to what humans are good
at so I could imagine we might need both
types of AI so emotion just on fish on
the each using essential that you're
going to have to cope with emotion as a
driver of if you like I think some types
of emotions so there's two reasons you
might want the one is so that we can act
they could these systems can empathize
and work better hand-in-hand with humans
yeah and the other thing is if they it
turns out the environments they're in
there aren't many external reward
signals they have to have some internal
drive to get them going in the right
direction
brilliant
it was a privilege I'm going to hand to
Nami climber from the IAT president the
IET in a second but Dennis
it's been wonderful of year
Thank You demos as the president of the
IET we're absolutely delighted to have
co-hosted this lecture with the Royal
Television Society and delighted to have
someone of your extraordinary caliber
Demi's events like today fulfil part of
the iet s charitable remit which is to
inspire inform and influence people and
I don't know about you but you sure as
hell have inspired informed and
influenced me on a topic that I believe
is going to change the world I love the
idea that your AI journey started with
games and the machine learning is done
through play pretty much the same as it
is for humans I've enjoyed the way that
you've made it all sound pretty
straightforward actually from our
hippocampus to imagining rats to the
quest for machine creativity and it just
sounded quite logical that your journey
to the point two of your mission which
is use AI to solve everything else seems
quite reasonable your quest for the AI
scientist to really tackle some of those
big important challenges so listening to
you it all sounds incredibly real and
feasible that AI can make a positive
difference to humanity and even if it's
not going to be directing in any movies
anytime soon so once again please join
me in thanking demis hassabis founder of
deep mind for an absolutely fantastic
lecture
and I would also like to like to thank
our feisty chair who did an excellent
job Tim Davey the CEO of BBC Worldwide I
think we've all been inspired informed
and influenced so it's been very nice
for me to be part of this thank you very
much for coming you'll be delighted to
hear that drinks are now served outside
thank you